Hello Everybody! My Name is Markiplier and Welcome Back to: West of Loathing
Now, we're going into this new area here- that I don't entirely know-
And someone by the name of Norton and his Ant-eye Virus did done steal all of our goodie goodies
Now I know There's more stuff to do in That Middle Section and we're Gonna get to that very soon
if There Is cool stuff to do. I got, now - you're ambushed by cow
Who's Hiding Behind a billboard. A big Billboard, big cow
That's a Reference I don't know. My God, my eyes. Gary you need a lot more powder inside of you
Well, Gary ain't gonna do me no good until he gets buffed up
Maybe I Should Have chosen a Different Idiom. I can See now how that might Have Been Confusing
I had No idea what you were Talking about from the get-Go so I (mumbles) Putrid cow Bile?
Why Would I drink that?
This is a little vial of  rancid cow bile That you kept for some Reason. yeah you got that right I don't no idea why but, we're Going, over the Last Custard stand
Sir i can't see a God-damned thing
Well Howdy There Welcome to the last Custard Stand I'm Custard man Stan and I make Custard like Only Tested men Stan Can?
Care to try some? Tell me About your Custard stand,  Custard stan man stan
not much to tell Just to play an Honest Custard stand Selling Plain Honest Custard, but it's the last one
But like The last One Before you get to frisco, or...? Last one in the whole Territory
Heck The last One in the whole World so far as I know but I can't swear to that
Are you sure it isn't the first? yep Because the first was also mine who was Father up North Whole dang Operation
Was ate by wasps stand and all
Gimme them sweet custards
Why do I want These sweet Custards? (cause custard is sweet and good?)
Nope I'm not gonna blow my money on Those Sweet Custards(aww :( ) Coz I've got to find something. Isn't There, there's an Old medicine Show
Over Here Maybe They know Something but There's, also, oh?
No I can't get back to that town for the Doctor they Probably, able to help me Mr.
Glyphs My fifth is the Fifth of the Burning I closing okay thank you very much for that I don't know what that means
Hello what are you doing
Gary, oh, no Goering is Hearing
A Smee Saying Antivirus This is terrible for real Everything Looks Really weird and it's Making me Dizzy
Goblin Doctors Are using Honey to curing A lot, of bad Sickness May be Needing a honey of Power Where do We find that
Oh Roy being Special Honey, Jellybeans Having that's one Hell of a Coincidence but it's Worth a shot let's get going, okay?
I don't need to be Here Roy being over in Roy beans House has obscure to this Goddamn Ailment Cure my Ant-Eye Virus
my Eyes Are Hurting Me and everybody at Home Obviously
Howdy Mumflr
(Mark again lost for words)
Gary you just said This
Gary Does This Jelly Bean Really cost Us 6000 meat, oh
Paraguayan Murder murder Bee Honey Jelly Bean, oh, oh?
Well Normally it does yeah?
Igess Seeing as how you Help me out with them Bandits and Goblins but Damn dirty hippies Let's Call
Her five Five Meat Really Yeah I reckon better Buy in a hurry for us changed my mind okay i'll Buy it you Hand
Over the meat you almost Feel Bad Because of the depths of the Discount but I'm Gonna eat This
Instantaneously Because I can't stand This Bleh you eat the Jelly Bean in your Vision Immediately Clears
Modern Medicine is Really Amazing when you get medicine in The Form of Jelly beans Which is Awfully Wonderful I think
Anyway Where are We going now
Cuz, We got to go back to frisco and then, wander Around as some the desolate Lonesome ghost
Fort Unnecessary
Alright I'll go to Fort unnecessary I don't know why Ford unnecessary is There or why, it's unnecessary in The first place but We'll See
Hello Sad-Looking Fort it's Kind of in Disrepair yeah the soldiers here Must not be very Good at Their jobs
Instructing soldiers To Cheering up A fort
Ok alright, well alright then see you Around Somebody Arranged These Cannons Haphazardly and Left Them out in The rain
Harried Looking Woman
Looked in A military Outfit darts in Front of the Doors you enter who know I can't believe I can't be Having Any More Misfits
In This Jerkwad you Can either swear to me that you're Half Way Competent heck even a Quarter and that you'll Help out This sort
of Crew of No-hoper so you can turn right Back in March Double-Time
okay
All Right I'm Gonna hold you to that Promise Come on in I'm Captain Harriet Davenport my name is Mumflr Fumperdink.
What's the Problem Cap?
Problemsssss
Yeah welcome to Camp Fubar (though it was camp unnecessary?)
Where Are all the army's IDiots And rejects r cent so they're out of my way I have to get up to my eyeballs trying to
Run this place Please Help These Morons Figure out Their Malfunctions so they can get the muster out Here and leave Me in Peace
You Give Me some Details Whoa, Boy
He'll Need to talk to them Individually for more Information but the Brief is you got a scout Who's blind as A bat
Cuckoo Can't Figure Out it Make Corned Beef on hash on toast guy Can't Load in Fire Cannon Without Blowing up someone or Maybe Shooting
It Backwards a guy who Somehow and I can't for the life of me Figure it out it's too
Bowlegged to Ride a Horse and a Kid who, was sent here Because he Can't Figure out a tie bow tie?
Well I just Keep Putting icing on the Cake, We have an Infinite Goblins Living in This Storage Shed?
Wow
Okay i Begin to see the Scope of your Complaint how you are not Just Whistling Dixie so what have you been Get
To do send Here you hear your Teeth Grinding Is he Growls at you, do you not ask, okay?
Well then I'll Just Take a look Around This Guy
Squints Real Hard as you Approach, howdy do I know you your Fuzzy Silhouette doesn't Seem Familiar
Nope i'm Passing Through what do you do here huh I'm Supposed, to be a scout
Oh and i broke my only Pair of glasses Without him. I can't See a dang thing
Try to Get you a new Pair
I'D be much obliged I hear There's a jeweler not too far from here he Probably
Could Grind me A pair of Lenses Just Tell them Make him Thick as a dickens I
Don't know how why why?
It's thick as the dickens A dickens or the dickens no Matter what I don't like it okay but I'll do that eventually
Yes, sputoon in here? dammit it's too much to ask for I got a medal of adequacy
This Medal was awarded to general fire Francoise what's his Name for his holy
Undistinguished Service Goes on your lapel that's Damn good
for being Holy
Undistinguished That Is A
Damn good Medal of Adequacy hey
When you couldn't Tell your friends about Markiplier you tell me Boy that Lets Players adequate?
Whatever he done do Is pretty much good Enough for Anything that I would want in my Viewing Pleasure?
Whatever okay, Howdy What's wrong
Well gee Wilkers I had a pretty good Job it's the generals personal assistant but I got Fired and reassign here what happened
It was great at First and Pretty good as Scheduling and I Can Break Through in an a+ Boot
Polisher But Then The general Went an Decided to Look more Serious and Sophisticated with a bowtie he's supposed
To be too due to time for him no good
No i could do A cheap ragged bolide or the clover itch but With the life of  me
i can't get a bowtie to Look right sterile Slippery out here but Brack Daughter Does go back to a dirt
alright I'll Help you out
Listen Grab the two ends Like this un's a little Shorter Grab the other end you tie it at round Lasso
put'er 'round your Torso Like that snip snap it up the Zigzag Side
Put the Strainer Up bit Down Over and Bend Over and Kiss your ass good-
bye and then Fold it under There and then you pull them tight.
Got it? (nope)
The two of you go back and Forth A few Times until it Gets Right Without poking Himself in The eye
I think I've got it Thanks alot, Wait I'll Show the general alright see, Ya I guess
You Shoot Yourself a wink hey,
Hey Stranger How You Doing over There looking Pretty Good it Would Be Cruel to loot These peoples supplies
Howdy Private Cooker, oh How Appropriate
Well Would be if I knew how to cook like Even a little bit Seems to be the trouble
We only got Two ingredients here I?
Cannot for The Life of me Figure out how to Combine Them what are the ingredients
Corned Beef Hash and Toast
Try to Help Them with A
Metaphor What have you thought as the toast
What have you thought of The toast as your Elbow?
He nods, Seeming to understand Where you're going with It and Think of the Corned Beef As
your Head (wut? o-o)
So I should...put the corned beef hash...under...no, next to...no, no...I'm sorry. I don't get it. Can we try again?
Thin of your toast as your elbow
And Corned Beef as a hole the Ground (Mark just stop)
A Shoe
Corned Beef as a Corncob Pipe, well Goddamn it okay think of the toast is a road map and
Corned Beef Is Shinola
okay, alright, You're not getting this okay think of the toast as your Elbow again, and the Corned Beef as a Corn Cob Pipe
You put it on your Elbow licky spitting and you       got it Makes sense no okay all right Think of the toast as
Shingle you
Put your Head in The Shingle With the Corned Beef You ain't no eat Corned Beef With no head on your single bow
You Ain't Gotta get that nah I didn't put that right Think of Think of a Shingle on your head
Think of it as a road map Leading you to Shinola
How About you Take your Shoe and you put it on your head
Nope okay all right, well how about you Take your Elbow and You take it all the way to shinola, oh?
a shoe and Shinola
What's Shinola?
Why is this a shoe no make shinola? I don't even Know what Shinola is Or where it is Or what it Is why it Is?
Alright Whatever all in The day's Work I
I Guess okay, well got that done I suppose
Good for me
Hi, Hello This Horse has Four left..*marki-giggles* legs
Sure it does
Howdy They Call me private bow legs I can see why you seem Uncomfortable
You Ain't Kiddin Look at my legs They're bent so far I Can Hardly touch both Knees at Once Walking Hurts Like A dickens
Can You did Can you
Tell Me how big is a dickens I'm not asking a personal Question I need to know
The Captain Said it Keeps you from Riding a, Horse yep, They're too wide Horse slips right right out A tween them
Huh I think I could ride a mule Though what with them being A tad lower to the Ground
I'm gonna bend your legs back
Excuse me I got some Strong
Squeezers Here Just bite Down on something don't scream, oh
You don't need a mule, this is Fixable
Well okay with some Gru...
*Mark can't control his laughter*
With Some grunts from you
Some Cries of Pain from him you normalize his le-*more laughing from markimoo* legs
oww! great Jumpin Jiminy man, oh, don't be A baby Look, they're much Straighter Now I
Guess i can't deny that
*Mark being a giggly bitch now*
He winces as he Mounts the Nearby horse and Rides out of Camp
hooray!
Hey what's the haps I'm Supposed?
To be A cannoneer but I'm they're all gonna have the same Voice but I'm Terrible at loading Cannons They Always Explode
Expect not the Way They're Supposed to Explode for us they don't explode at all
Huh the only Time I ever going to fire right Cannonball Knocked
My Sergeant's hat Off and he was Standing Behind me! still can't Figure out how that happened
So they assign me to this loser Squad and Said I can't Report Back for a proper Duty
until I figure out how to load a Cannon right
Give Them the Book I remember I got Cannon Loading for Idjits
Earlier Here Maybe This will, oh
Well Let's see he Flipps Through the Pages Which is A big Numbered Diagrams, oh?
You Take the stick back out before you put the cam ball in well I certainly Sounds?
Easier They, did not have the Same Voice all right he, Carefully, Follows, Along the Directions in the Book and Successfully Fires A Cannonball
Over The Wall The fort I'll do it wow great Thanks a lot
I will get mine go get my new assignments right away
cool good luck Guy
Congratulations
Good Job Sign in Front Says Important gun Storage no Goblins you open the door and Crack Take a peek Naturally the Shed is crammed
Full of Goblins to the Ceiling They're Barely Recognizable as Individual Goblins wow
Jeez Paul what Let Gary, Seeing Gary Takes a peek in Reels Back in Shock Slamming the door, oh
Gross
Awful A goblin Popping in There Maybe two
izat What Happened all Those Spores and Know Where to going, oh Growing Into new Goblins and They Just Smooshing all up
Probably Better not Mess With that Shed it might explode, well that is Something I am not Gonna deal With howdy
Cap Howdy Fumperdink You're Doing great Job out There Looks like only One Hapless Goofball Left to Fix
Oh yeah the glasses guy, okay, alright I'm Gonna find that Jewelers Cabin over There
No, One's Gonna get in my way on the Way They're right over El Vibrato aww, I don't have a Battery Jewelry Shop Inside That Seems
Untrustworthy all Gary is Hearing About This a goblin Jewelry-Making you Really yes A Famous Goblin
Artisan Nam intrigued, oh?
Hello, oh!
Hello A Customer, why, hello welcome to master Gerald's Jewelry Shop howdy are you Master Gerald?
Oh, no, master gerald, was Back There at
His Workbench, I'm Just his assistant and Translator A goblin Jewel smith you Bet in your Britches Sonny
Oh you, betting your britches Sonny and not forgetting it he Says that's right the finest Jeweler in The Territory
Well what do you know?
I don't see Anything on Display Though Master Gerald only Does bespoke Work if You bring him in a
Sufficiently Valuable Gemstone He'll Craft it Into A fine Ring for you for A fee Good thing I didn't sell my stink Stone, oh?
Good Thing I just took my Pants off Good thing I didn't do that
No Trash Rocks I need a pair of Eyeglasses
Huh!
Having Some Old Soda Bottles for Grinding Down Should working fine he Says yes We have some Glass of the?
Finest Optical Qualities I remember me Maybe Later?
Master Gerald Takes a look at the rocks you have with you my effluvious emerald!
Woo
Sets it in A fine Ring for you
bah! all of
Trash and Garbage Being The ring that Is that this Is the most similar to the ring Around the Waterline of a filthy Toilet
Hilarious and I paid Five Hundred Meet to get this Ring
Great Thanks Anyway Though Alright How About you do the glasses Thing
Sure
Clerk Invites you to the back to have A seat in Their Living Area While Master gerald Works to Cutting and Grinding some Glass and
Lenses and Setting Them Into Wireframes
You Flip Through A goblin Magazine while you wait the lead Article Seems to be About social Interaction with Humans and the value of Occasionally
Pretending to be Dumber Than You actually are
okay, Close Enough for Government Working
Master Gerald Is Completed your spectacles with the utmost, degree of Craftsmanship
very Thick Spectacles
Here You are, well that cost me Five Hundred Goddamn Goddamn Meets?
your Eyebrows are getting Kind
Of Wild pluck em that's Better
This Must be the assistance Toilet it doesn't Have any Rough Rusty Scrap Metal bolted on to be a goblin toilet yay
All Right Goblin bed Maybe, hmm mmm
There A Dining Table but they Left out a stack of Magazine for Customers to look at
While They're Waiting They're all in Goblin Though most of Them are Goblin
Celebrity Gossip and Crossword Puzzles Have Already Been Filled in Ok alright see you byyyeee
bye, ok
We got what We Needed alright so we Can go back to for it Unnecessary Now and Hopefully This is Unnecessary Adventure with A?
Belcher of Hilly Flaps or Whoa, ok alright bang, oh get him, Gary, Gary, that's not getting him, you're About to be Smooshed
Yep you got Smooshed Gary, sorry about that Didn't mean for that to happen but it Happened Nonetheless
Alright Back for it Unnecessary what, do We got going on over
Hello I've got some very Thick Spectacles he Takes the glasses and Puts Them on and Looks Around
Well I'll be Never realized what a Dump this place Is
Climbs Atop the Watchtower and Peers, over the Countryside it Worked I can See a dang thing
Hooray!
Great cool all right I did it great Job
Everyone's dealt with an out of Here and that Means I'm Finally out of this hellhole too
Do we ever Cross Paths again I really, owe you one?
Frisbees her Clipboard snaps you a salute and Marches out of the fort, oh!
Well Lookie-Lookie me Looki Looking Me and how Goody-Goody I am aha
Abandoned mine you Say
I'Ll Check it out Woo
alrighty Then, well This Seems interesting
Anything Over Here There's A Shiny Thing in Here
Whoaaa Strange Silvery Crystal Silver and Silver Colored not Silver Colored in The sense that it's Made I Can Take that to the Jeweler
Probably Maybe I'm Just Guessing but uh
Hello Can you lose some Up Can you align it with a wrench
Can I ride it Down
To this abandoned mine That's Probably Gonna Get me Killed Probably i mean if I just Had to venture A guess on to everything
Killing Me Out here it's Probably Gonna give me a kill
Get give me A get gonna it's gonna kill me
Somethin's Cures Poisoning By Making vomit But Luckily Medical science Had Confirmed That vomiting is a cure to basically every type of Poisoning
Great gross Blood Building Tonic this Bad Medicine Promises to Increase your volume the volume
and
Viscosity of your Blood
great! The Switches Long Since Rusted away to Uselessness
So, we got a lot of Useless Bullshit here all right
Well, Whoa, what's up with These weird rocks, oh?
I got Teleported, okay, no Cousteau Pot Jalopy Facility
Okay, ooh punch Cards cool, I need Those all right Cylinder okay, well I don't have a keystone but Close
Alrighty Then
So there's Gotta Be Something in These Caverns right
No Nothing over There is that a Meat vein?
hell ya it is, oh, hell yeah, oh, yeah Whoa, well that's Probably Bad?
Mining gear Dynamite all the Goodies Stuff okay, well this looks Bad
ooh Cultist Camp good for me Let's See the note Says Dear Jeff Got Called up North to Deepest delve See
You Soon Praise be Roberto Sincerely geoff
all Right then
Sarsaparilla Come Nighttime Sas Parallel, aural Are all right, well okay?
There's Some Point of This
Long Since rusted away to uselessness not that it was all that useful before Giving the track Layout
alright
hello
oh
hi snakes how are you doing?
I got the Jumbo who you Guys Look Tough that Whelp Didn't Think about that one
eh you're dead
Bang okay good all right you've got, some good skins off of Them but what were They Hiding Meat!
Meat
So much meat, oh my God, so much meat, was that Only Thing that was in This mind. Was that it, oh goof me
Goof me Hard
Right Past A woman who's running Along the desert Trail on Foot Although I'd Say Running it's a slow run with an odd loping Gate
she's dressed Oddly - No hat Just A thin Strip of Fabric Tied across her Forehead
Like Clothing and Strange Soft Looking Boots That Barely Even Come up through ankles
Everything all right are you running away from something something pretty slow like Maybe A desert Tortoise no not out ah no jogging but
jogging! I invented it, it is like Slow running, well Where i'm from?
We just Walk Better Exercise if You go Faster I'm fast enough to Actually get Away for Anything Though A?
Full Outrunning Wears You out that isn't as
Healthy so healthier Than being eaten By a bear I look I'm not being Chased by bear I've Never Been Chased
By A bear yes it's Obvious, you're alive and not Mangled Lumps it's about Physical Fitness Bears aren't an Issue okay
You're Right Thank you all right Many bears out Here in The desert
Pack Coyotes
Oh you'd, be in Real trouble it's A very Frustrating Conversation they tear you to Shreds Even Without Those Goofy-Looking Shoes Matches I made Myself
Goofy They're Pretty Goofy I mean what good are They if you can't even run
Properly in Them but They don't prevent then Certainly I'm Gonna Protect your ankles from Coyote bites they'll be Perfectly good for Kicking your ass
Gosh all this Exercise has Made you kind of belligerent get Down off That Horse how about
We see if You Can Catch me
you ride Away the Jogger runs after you for A bit Yelling but as Predicted you Can't Catch you gotta be the shoes
Yep all right Good good encounter good Encounter
Well Hello There you got to get That Train Back This is Embarrassing
Smee points to that Set of Deep Ruts off to the side of the Railroad track, no
norton's Taken The Train Uh-oh I see, what I need to do?
Follow The Tracks you Jump on Templars Black and Ride like the wind
Following The Railroad Tracks Back Into The Desert When you Finally Catch up you stand up on templar Saddle and Leap Onto the back of
The Train Like A real Badass
Just Barely Catching the Edge of the roof and Pulling Yourself Up here's Hoping you don't have to do that again your Stuntman Could Have
Been Killed
Looks Like Gary Decided not to join you on account of not Having a stuntman so you're on your Own until you get back to?
Frisco, oh
oh
all Right then
Hello, oh!
You're Feeling Neither Fair nor Square Take the train Back By Force I'll be back I'll be back Excuse Me Labels Hand Fruit Pickled fig
Pickled Pig Knuckles I'm not even Gonna Try that someone Carefully Stack These with This and up Arrows all Pointing in Different Directions
All Right good for me This Barrels labeled Pickled Crackers all right Barrel is labeled nubs all right
Oh Can I get Safecracking
Gonna get it I got a lot of xp bam!
Just enough, oh
Cargo Car key, okay, so key to the car of the train Should Have Said key Instead of Keys
Oh, okay, i get it ooh it's the door Into the next car it's Locked With an unpickable Plot Brand Lock
Unlock it you Hear Norton Scurrying Forward on the Roof
okay, whoa, ah, hi, hello who are you why are you here I Didn't Guys Look Angry and Confused
oh
Say I'll be right Back Whoa all right then Whoa
Well then, oh?
These Guys Are so preoccupied with the door to the rear of the car they
Don't notice you Prowling Around behind Them the one in The back has a Shiny key Attached to his belt it must be the key to
The Dining Car Because it has Dining Car Stamped Into it With Big Letters big Enough to Read from here
I Got A lot of Moxie I'm gonna Grab them haBoink
Burglar Has Become The Burglee
okay Unlock, weee
Okay, oh, nice Flowers
It's got one of Those Fancy Silver Dome Things Investigate huh you
Never Wanted Anything more in your life then that Would lift up this Dome and See what's under it but you're not sure you can
Muster The Amount of Culinary Expertise it Requires to Properly Reveal A
Dish of Such Presumed Quality i'm Gonna do it
Voila, oh it's his Cream pie Shaving Cream Lunatics are Running the Food Service on this Train are the Clowns
are They Clown's They might Be Clowns Seems like something Clowns Would do mmm welded Shut over There what's going on Up here
Oh yeah, what's Going on There's Norton Wait what You've Got A clear Shot at
Him from if You want to Throw that pie At him yeah all right, oh yeah?
Whoosh
I love it, I love it, I l... woo
no Thank you all right why is this Guy Hanging around on the top of a moving Train with a knife
I don't know but I'm not gonna find out, oh what do We got here. Maybe you better Read the Note on the Wall first
I'm trying to ah There
We go the note Says I've Hidden the key to the Forward
Passenger Car in My Luggage to Make it Easier for me to murder everybody in the Sleeper car
Sincerely The Train Murderer Come to the roof of the Sleeper car in the next 55 Minutes if You want a murderin
Crazy okay all right then so
When a sleeping Compartments Must belong to the murderer Maybe it's the first one
You Open the door, the sole occupant is a little Boy about ten Years Old Wearing blue suiting Knickerbockers, oh?
Hello Sir is Something Wrong Nothing you need to?
Worry About Kid I'm on the trail of A bad Guy?
you Mean A murderer sir I'm Pretty Sure There's one on this Train and They
Don't Call me the World's Greatest detective for Nothing what's your name Kid I probably shouldn't say sir
There might be A Copyright Thing okay, well I'm Pretty Sure I can
Handle This Just Let Me ask you one Question then you Should lock the door After I'm gone I
I Understand Sir what Would you like to know are you on the roof of the train Excuse
Me the murderer Left A note Saying is on the roof of the Train are you I
Know sir I'm it I'm in My Passenger Compartment Good that'll be all thank you
Also what's this?
There's Nothing Without Knowing Which Piece of Luggage, oh I got you, hello
Excusemuah is there Someway I might be of assistance miss well no miss you
Sorry to bother you but There's a murderer on the Loose and I'm Checking the Passenger Compartments
Sacrebleu This Is very Serious Moname allow me to Proffer, do you the use of my
little gray cells, I don't know what that means, I don't know what
Language You're Speaking it's not A very good Convincing ask Accent that to be sure Let me ask you this One Question why
Certainly I am at your Service
Are you on the roof of the train?
Roof of A train Monsieur Right Now
That's Right, nooh i'm here Conversing with you
All Right Thank you
You Open the door a Third Passenger
Compartment and Find Nobody Inside
Hmm since The Note of the murderer Said he was gonna be on the roof of the Train that Could Mean?
He Couldn't Begin This Passenger Compartment and Since There's
No One inside the Passenger Compartment Whoever the Compartment belongs to Can only by Process of Elimination be on the roof?
Which Means The Person who rented this Compartment must be the murderer Probably
The Only Clue you find in Here is a luggage Ticket Though there's the number Three on it
All Right the Only Passenger in This Compartment is a Middle-Aged woman who, was writing something in A notebook she looks up as
You enter Greets You with A friendly Northeastern Accent why
Hello
Is there Something you need dear I don't know what A northeastern accent Is so i'm Gonna go with This sorry to bother you ma'am
I don't want to alarm you but There's a murderer on board the train and I'm Investigating a murder on the Train
My Goodness That Would be a Wonderful Brenna's for my next Novel
True why not Anyway I just need to ask you a question go ahead A dear
According my evidence The murderer Is on the roof of the train are you on the roof of the train?
No no dear Alright Thank you for your time Would you like a meat pie They're homemade
no Thanks Just have a look at this Playing Card before you go
Bye
Now I'm pretty sure the Lady here isn't the murderer Probably, oh you find bag Number Three it has the key
Passenger Car Inside That's very Strong Corroborating Evidence for your Theory of who the murderer Is
Mm-hmm I dundid deuce This real good like, alright, farewell
Oh you, Finally Make it to the passenger Car
One Car Back From the locomotive Which May be Confusing if You Thought locomotive meant the entire
Train So i could Just say the Engine except that
Also Reserves to the Engine Itself that is the actual steam Engine That Makes A train go and not Just The front of the car
of the Train Anyway you're in The Passenger Car Suddenly Norton Clambers in The Window
He must Have Dramatically Clung to the side of the Train in Order to reveal at
The Last Minute that he Actually Hadn't Been Defeated dang it he runs Into the
Well Front most car at the train and locks the door what a Jerk
Maybe you could get some of the rest of the Passengers to Help you Break Down the door and Arrest him, Maybe you could
Just Kick that door Down and Shoot him until he Can't bother Anybody Anymore
Up to you!
Well Alright Then
It's Profess Oriole Looking Guys Frowning at an Actual Sheet of Paper and Occasionally scribbles Down on a pencil and then erasing what he Just
Wrote
Excuse me Can you Help me With something
Sorry, I'm busy that's my wife or my daughter God no she Could do With something to Keep her Occupied
What are you Working on it's Quite Academic I'm Sure you wouldn't Understand?
try me
well if you must know I'm a scholar of foreign Antiquities I'm Attempting to resolve this ancient Conundrum for the far east
He Shows you a Sheet of Paper Covered With Little Boxes some of Which have Numbers in Them
I'Ll solve it for you that's a sudoku my little Brother thinks the're for Babies
What Look this Box can't be A three blah blah blah Filling the rest of the Puzzle
Well Damn it what fun is it if you just Solve it for me
sorry, will you Help me Break Down the door to the Engine Arrest the Emperor I guess I got nothing better to do
Alright cool then this woman Just Ignores you?
Guys Totally Pram Ticking Which means Which is A word I made Up that Means Ranting and a frantic panic everything
Everyone Else Is ignoring him as Hard as They Can hey Buddy you, okay, it's a lie
We're Never Gonna get to frisco brisket ball Brawler, doesn't even Exist They've Been Testing to See how Long
We got can survive on complimentary Peanuts and Bottled Water you know They're Driving Us into the desert They've got A government Camp
They're Gonna Use our Organs as Fuel for Eilean Flying machines wow
I don't know what percussive Maintenance is slap him requires percussive Maintenance Love that but. I don't have that Unfortunately
Yeah what do you got this woman is Focusing?
On her Knitting and ignoring the general Commotion she must have Been Knitting the whole Trip because of the Scarf She's
Made Could Accommodate a whole Marching Band Talk to her Excuse me Ma'am Whatever it is I want
No part of it I keep Myself to Myself and I've no Desire to get Involved Thank you very much
cmon, it's norton, the guy stole a train and I need help to go arrest him or we'll never get to frisco
I mean everything will sort Itself out in The end and in The Meantime I have Plenty of wool
Can i level Up my Hornswogglin
No I need a little more, oh
Damn it okay fine then little Girls Peering out the Window Clearly Bored hi There busy
No all my toys and Friends are in our Luggage and it's Boring and I hate it
Do you want to Help me out With something Really Important
Huh like what, well A bad Guy Took!
Over The Engine Car and I need some People to help Break Down the door and Arrest him what this Job Just a little Girl
Hey Now that's not A good Attitude don't ever Let Everyone and even To tell you Candy don't don't don't let Anyone Tell you Knowing
You know Can do no all right yeah, well bless that Crooks Face in that's the spirit you got to Pay me Advance
Geez you're Learning a, little too fast all right what do you want I like Stuffed animals, oh right Back
All Right Can you Make Us stuff the animal
You might get all right Fine then Jeez all right Flipping Through a Book
Title Birds of The Western Territory Since Most of the places Desert isn't very Long Book, Excuse me ma'am
yes A Crazed Psycho
Was taking Over The Train engine Car and I need Volunteers to Help Break Down the door and arrest him
oh
My i certainly Couldn't be of Any Help I'm very Conflict Diverse
What if I told you he hates Birds and Is determined to Outlaw them from the Territory After he Seizes Power
that's very Sly but I know You're Only Saying that because you, saw the Book how, yeah you got me There
Any other Ideas to Convince me Suddenly you Hear a tapping and Tapping at the passenger Window. What the russell
Russell you open The Window and your Pet Crow russell Flaps in and Purchase on your Shoulder hey, Buddy good to see ya caw
Oh my Gosh what a beautiful Crow and he Knows you, well Sure Me and russell go
Way Back Right Buddy
caw I
Rescued Him from A Cat when he was only Just out of the nest and Raised him as A Pet I set him free When
I Left home Recently what's he doing here has he Been Following you since Then
"No, he probably just happened to be flying by and spotted me on the roof of the train and recognized me."
"Crows are crazy smart like that."
"That's amazing!  Oh, what I wouldn't give to have an avian friend like that."
"Well, I'm still gonna be doing a lot of traveling after this, I figure, so I I can't really drag Russell along with me."
"Buuuuut, I bet Russell wouldn't mind being pals with a nice lady in Frisco who helped save the train."
"Whaddya think, Russ?"
"Caw!"
"...flaps over to perch next to the lady."
"My goodness!  How could I refuse?"
"It's a pleasure to meet you, Russell!  My name's Annabel."
"Awesome, I'll let you know when we're ready."
Okay, but there's a problem-
Oh!
Overweight man in Three-Piece suit Bowler hat is Probably a banker or something
Cuz Eyes Are Closing his Postures Relaxed but the Clench
of his jaw Betrays his Aggravation I excuse me Herim
What is it?
Crazy Jerk Calling Himself The Emperor Norton Has Hijacked The Train and I need Volunteers to Help Me Bust down the door and arrest him
I see and
I'd rather not that sounds Quite Strenuous perhaps Even Dangerous cmon Please?
No I don't think so i'm Quite Comfortable Here and I prefer Dewey Dewey Tris Please
"Again, no I'm supposed to avoid things that might raise my blood pressure."
"Pretty please with sugar on top?"
"Sugar is one of those things..."
"Pretty please with...gravy on top?"
"Gravy is another.  Please just leave me alone."
Please please please PLEASE.  PLEEAASE.
Please please please please please please.
"I said no!  Stop asking."
"Please please please!  I'll stop asking if you say yeeees."
PLEEAASE.
"All right!  God!  Fine!  I'll help, just leave me alone!"
Not bad, alright, well, good for me.
I don't have everybody.
Hmmm.
I don't know how to deal with this.
I don't think I can leave, can I?
Ahhhh!
"It's the back of the train, hop off and head back to Frisco."
Okay!
Well, I almost did it!  I almost got to where I needed to go!
But I didn't quite get to exactly where I needed to go.
So I'm gonna end this episode here-
and I'm gonna find the *MUSIC* and I need to get
Percussive Maintenance before I'll be able to do that and
*MUSIC* my Hornswagllin' *MUSIC* So Thank you everybody so much for watching,
let me what you think in the comments down below
-and as always, I will see you in the next video!  Buh-bye!
Sub to Mark!  Thank the guys/girls/others that created these subtitles for you pplz!